in fast ax Cipher enters the film behind
the wheel of a DeLorean Alpha 5. a yet
to be released limited edition homage to
the DeLorean Motor Company's Heyday with
the iconic dmc-12 the back to the
futuristic look of the car is fitting
for Cipher's techno-terrorist aesthetic
and since the car isn't out yet it's
safe to assume that she stole one during
the big action sequence in Rome Han
drives a boxy Alfa Romeo with an orange
and black color scheme it's the exact
same coloring that his Mazda RX-7 has in
the Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift and
of course Jacob gets to drive his old
blue 5.0 fox body Mustang which was
first seen during the flashback scenes
in F9 the fast Saga Jacob references his
drag race with dom while talking to
little Brian clearly Brian isn't all
that impressed by Mustangs as his
project car shown earlier in the movie
is actually a Chevy SS given that his
dad loves Dodge and his uncle loves Ford
it feels right that the kid goes with a
third major American car manufacturer